dr nash in total transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transforming lives all across the valley
and today she joins us to discuss her
success stories
dr nash is always great to see you and
i'm super excited about today because
today we're going to talk about your
success stories with your clients and
there's so many success stories to talk
about but i want to talk about patient
number one and patient number one is you
and your success are losing 80 pounds 13
years ago you've kept the weight off you
look stunning tell us more about it yeah
so i'm somebody that actually struggled
with obesity all of my life i started
gaining weight when i was eight years
old and that took me on a 25-year battle
with a with obesity over 36 failed diet
and it wasn't until i shifted my focus
and started correcting damage and let go
of the weight loss that my body finally
responded well it's working you look
beautiful let's start with catherine
i went from a size 14 to a size 6 in 30
days i no longer suffer from
fibromyalgia and i no longer suffer from
depression catherine dropped four dress
sizes and one of the things she said
there that jumped out to me is she's no
longer dealing with those issues of
depression
right she no longer deals with
fibromyalgia or depression and she
dropped from that 14 to a six in 30 days
so this isn't just that she dropped some
dress sizes she dropped weight it was a
miracle it was amazing how she
transformed
and it's just not weight loss it's a
lifestyle change that you're doing her
her life was going down one path she met
with you and she's going down a
completely different path right now and
it's such a great path that she's going
down
yeah exactly she's holding the weight
loss which is what most of us are
looking for we're not looking for weight
loss we're looking to hold a normal
weight that's what she wanted to and now
her body's helping her achieve that goal
instead of preventing it let's take a
look at these photos of derek we're
looking at derrick right now and derek
derek is jacked he lost 80 pounds derek
is on his way to being the next rock the
guy looks fantastic
yeah he really does so this was a
retired policeman from milwaukee and you
know what happens when you retire you
just kind of let things go and so when
we saw him 80 pounds of extra body fat
lots of it located around his midsection
and he took our program that we built
for him and he just crushed it yeah i
mean he's just a powerhouse now we have
a video here to watch this is becky i
lost 42 pounds on dr nash's program i'm
seven pounds away from my goal if i can
do this i can do anything 42 pounds five
dress sizes tell us more about becky so
becky actually found out about me
because she's a school teacher and one
of the moms did my program and that mom
found her in the classroom upset and
crying because her body wasn't
responding and so they had a short talk
and they literally called me right from
the classroom we were able to find out
what her underlying issues were and
turned it around for her and now she's
at her goal weight just where she wants
to be
every week you have a special for us
what do you have going on this week
i do so the first step in order for us
to find out what needs to be done and
how we can help you reach your goal is
we have to do that online evaluation
which is normally 97
but when people say that they saw me on
las vegas now with jc obviously i'm
going to bring something special to the
table so we have 10 spots available
right now online at dr nash dot com
forward slash eval that's only 9.97
so really just a small investment to
find out what's blocking you from
getting to your normal weight and
holding it
thank you again to total transformation
for sponsoring this segment visit
drnash.com forward slash eval to take
advantage of our special offer las vegas
now we will be right back